boulet care podcast
we got the homie stupid youngs what's
the deal what's the deal
new album dropping this friday dropping
this friday by the time this comes out
it'll be out
so it's out now um and
i feel like you've had a very slept on
2020
yup for sure you know what i'm saying
like i know things are definitely
different as far as you know
show money is not out you know just
there's obviously a lot of revenue
streams that are kind of
closed up for artists during this
pandemic but how have you kind of
handled things
it's been a blessing in the curse
because [ __ ] i bought my house this year
and i saw that yeah this year and uh
i get to spend more time with my son
because i'm on the road but
it's it's been it's like a blessing and
a curse you know what i'm saying they
stop one source of income but if you're
a hustler
you don't get in a gang of different
other ways for sure man
yeah and it's it's crazy because i
remember i i've been seeing you
you're a family man yeah you know what
i'm saying and and you don't hide that
and you know
as am i you know i'm married i got two
kids but um
how has fatherhood changed you just as
far as just
you know on a day-to-day basis and and
just as as a
as a man like you know what i mean that
[ __ ] changes everybody i feel like
it's this it's a different type of
feeling like it's uh
it's a feeling that i never knew that
was there until i had my son you know
what i'm saying
and i see him start saying his first
words call me that papa or dad whatever
it's different of course it's going more
if you have a kid going more
that's everybody that cares about their
life and their kids gonna motivate them
to grind harder that's a given
but like to be able to teach him stuff
and he learned you know what i'm saying
just
just the balance is the balance with
everything because like
i thought i'm trying to do this music
[ __ ] 100 so i got to balance out the
time with my homies
in the hood or whatever the music my
family
um you know i'm saying business my son
and it's it's hard to find that balance
but what the quarantine [ __ ] they cut
out shows
but i i get to spend more time with my
son you know and it just taught me like
to teach him and wake up every day teach
him something new and this
is it's a beautiful thing it's an
unconditional feeling yeah it's crazy
because like
i think that's you know like you said it
unlocks something you didn't even know
you
like was inside of you for sure it's
like discovering a new sense or some
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] is wild so you bought a crib
this year
which is first of all congratulations
thank you thank you uh
did you get a good deal on it uh
i ain't gonna lie we was kind of rushing
into it because i was paying like
[ __ ] 3 600
a month in rent for rent that's what i'm
paying right i'm paying
like 34 right now in the condo though
and at downtown l.a i'm like
i'm like [ __ ] man all this money you
added up that's like
seven bands in two months yeah that's a
lot of money that's 14 000 in four
months
like this should need to be going
somewhere else so yeah i got a good deal
i got a cool deal and then the real
estate um we already have relations with
them because they're like related to my
girl family
i'm saying so it was kind of it kind of
works out the price went up already i
just threw my son's second birthday
there
and then she came over said oh your
house went up let me know if you want to
sell it i'm like
nah i just got in here we go keep hold
we go hold on to it because
yo that's what's dope about la is i
don't feel like i feel like it's
whenever real estate takes a dip la
certain places like la and new york
usually really don't get it affected
because the
the man never is gonna like people want
to live here exactly yup
hey so um i was telling you this before
before
the cameras came on like bro like i feel
like
you've had a crazy few years but
you're one of the biggest factors when
it comes to
the west coast [ __ ] but i feel like you
still don't necessarily get
the recognition the recognition that you
probably deserve i think
now i know like racist buyership i think
there's a lot of it's just it's new to
people like i'm asian you know what i'm
saying
like i still got work to do i still got
um doors to knock down and [ __ ]
i just feel like that that plays a big
part because i see a lot of
[ __ ]
saying you know i'm the biggest
independent artist
out here in la who does these numbers or
i'm the
who does these numbers independent or
who does this does that when really i
look at my [ __ ] and i look at their [ __ ]
no no competition [ __ ] but rap is
competitive but it's like
i do these numbers and my name don't get
mentioned you know what i'm saying
like yo i've i've had conversations with
the guys at empire you're like one of
the
biggest artists as far as just revenue
at the at empire they say i stream very
well i [ __ ] with empire for life for
sure
yeah you stream very well those yo it's
crazy because
another guy like you know someone you've
got a great relationship with is mozzie
um who shared an empire statement
what is your biggest statement you've
gotten do you like
not to be in your pocket like you know
you get your your monthly empire
you know uh what i get like oh that was
like
yeah like that's like the biggest month
you've had for it like like off your
music
[ __ ] my whole my whole my whole my whole
life
for sure nah but i touch i touch a lot
of money with impart
you know what i'm saying i touch a lot
of money with empire but let's talk
about the first time i seen some [ __ ]
so the first time i seen some [ __ ] i was
eating
i think i was i was i was still hustling
too i'm over here paying for all my
music [ __ ] trying to make ends meet
paying for that apartment in downtown
because i just have my son
so he's two now that's about two years
ago yeah this is like when mando dropped
you know what i'm saying
and then um i get a call from nema i was
eating that food at a full restaurant
with my girl
and i'm like and i'm i'm over before i
got that call from nina i'm talking to
homes like we need to make this place
make this place all right
or you know do little [ __ ] to hustle
right and then i get the call from nima
you're like man how come you didn't tell
me that we haven't been paying you it's
just been stacking up and stacking up
and i was just like what the [ __ ] it
didn't he just you know it was um he's
like yeah i'm a sen
do you want to check or i'm gonna send
it to your account like i'm saying to
him accounts like how much is he's like
57 000 or something like but it was just
that's like the first
big number you know what i'm saying [ __ ]
and i was just like hell yeah i was like
i need that run that yeah my places
didn't go through like 10 minutes ago
right like i'm over here send up plays
yeah but i got more
more from more from them for sure um you
know after that but it started getting
bigger and bigger but i remember that
was the first like
chunky like that was just no that was
the first check ever you know what i'm
saying
wow yeah that's a hell of a first rap
check yeah i'm like what the [ __ ]
what do you think um cause you have fans
that are very very
they're like it's like a cult following
right yeah they're very dedicated
um what do you think it is about what
you've brought to the marketplace and
what it is that like
people resonate with so much because the
stupid young fans are very passionate
fans
yeah just like um i think like the uh
the the type of music i put i was like
because i i like to do versatile [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying like sometimes
i rap about some deep [ __ ] they relate
to
and then sometimes i write about some
fun [ __ ] like some some partying [ __ ]
i kind of like to do a little bit of
everything when i drop a project that's
why i think that
like if they feel like in this type of
mood they'll listen to this song or if
they feel like they want to turn up on
the weekend don't listen to this
that's why i feel like you know that's
why they [ __ ] with versus versatility in
it
um you uh you just tapped in with draco
who just got out
we just had him up here last week yeah
um you guys did the little boozy record
shot the video did you did you and draco
have a relationship prior to him getting
locked up
yeah because way before we we was locked
up as kids
for like nine months and i was real it
was real tight it was real close
he didn't rap at that time so you knew
him since you guys were kids you guys
were locked up together
like juvenile juvenile woods and they
put us in a foster care
um group home and we yup was together
and [ __ ]
damn so you guys got a friendship
outside of this rapture yeah he bought
me i remember because
on the weekend they let you go with your
family on the weekends only friday to
sunday he came back on the home pass
like i got you something he got made a
little gift it was my because i turned
well i turned 16 in there or some [ __ ]
he got me a a's hat oh
yellow yeah that's crazy so it was like
it's crazy because he got out and just
recorded like
that whole project yeah like in like a
week
when i was locked up i had book
composition books all written you know
what i'm saying yeah
so you're not gonna like all of it but
you want like at least a good amount
like where you can put out
a couple projects and [ __ ] for sure um
with this new album
um talk about what was what's the
motivation behind the title
i love the cover from here on from here
on out
in the cover i think there's a lot of
got it there's a lot of meaning wrapped
up in that cover too yeah it is
it's like and and well it goes for
everybody even like whether you're a
rapper or you're just a
nine-to-five worker with kids or
something it's like
i feel like a big part of life that a
lot of people don't try to work on is
balance
yep balance and balance is very
very important that's why when they say
times money they're really talking about
balance and that picture just shows
balance
because it's like how do i balance this
[ __ ] out where i don't
do i'm not too much in the streets where
i get caught up or i'm not
too much into music where i forgot about
my people you know what i'm saying it's
like it's just a balance
that's why and i had a hard time from
leaving the streets and [ __ ] like that
so
i just told myself like from here on out
like i'm
i gotta give more percentage to my music
than i am in the street
yeah man i i was going to say cause i
heard you say that earlier like
have you noticed because you know if if
you just kind of see what's been going
on right
there's been a lot of people getting
caught up with cases
and
people dying people getting killed bro
like the same [ __ ] um
company two two empire artists you know
vaughn was with empire
yeah yeah yeah and uh
it's just it's just crazy because
i saw um i think it might have been meek
someone just said that being a rapper is
the most dangerous job in the world
dangerous drop it's a dangerous job if
you from the streets is a dangerous job
but also if you're not
cause aren't you a target yeah you're a
target like if you if you're on if you i
feel like any anywhere you go
if you go to a different city it's like
oh this guy's in town
yeah that might be you know a lick for
someone to hit
and then like it's a it's a target
because like the [ __ ] you did before
you know what i'm saying like they know
you were super active they know you was
doing this like if you from a
notorious game you for sure are taught
it just triple it you know what i'm
talking about it just triples it like
vaughn was a notorious
his hood is everywhere worldwide so he
did his was triple
but then but then again at the same time
is it that is it and never how do you
say that inevitable
inevitable right because like you could
be
you could be so on point like so like
think you're on point your homies on
point but
a lot of the times it's unexpected like
it's like
vaughn that was quan around homie what i
don't speak about who it is but
that wasn't his enemies like that ain't
you know what i'm saying that ain't the
other side
of the enemies in the city right it was
some rap it was some rapper [ __ ]
that's what's crazy rapper [ __ ] nipsey
wasn't his enemies you know what i'm
saying
like you're just and is it is it it's
unexpected
unexpected yeah yeah no definitely like
that's what i wanted to ask you about
because i
obviously you know your track record is
clear like
do you find yourself maybe like
having your circle become a little bit
smaller or maybe watching out like yo
man i might not need to go
do a b and c or be around a b and c
anymore like i used to be just because
now i got so much more to lose
yeah yeah i'll be like that but it's
like
that [ __ ] i i did like back then you
know what i'm saying before the rapture
took off
it um like i don't need to be in the
hood you know i'm saying i don't need to
prove anything or do anything because
a lot of the times is it's not my homies
you hear about rappers saying their
homies hating them because they be like
oh man he's just a rapper he's not in
the hood he never what would he do for
the hood
but that's the other way around i'll be
in my section and my homies like what
you doing here man
or like damn don't you do that music
[ __ ] bro [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
and they actually tell me to like like
what i'm doing here and [ __ ] like that
so i guess that that would just be my
advice man it's like you got something
special bro
and like i think that we've seen a lot
of examples
this year that that has just kind of
shown like
it might like [ __ ] you got you come from
that background
staying out the way might be the way you
know what i'm saying for sure
off smarter who's smarter for chauffeur
show
um i was just talking to you in the
lobby because i got a mozzie plaque and
i was like yo when you're getting one of
these man
and i know i know you're close we're
talking about ando with mando right yeah
i keep checking the numbers with uh my
boy gentry from empire
um it's close it's getting close it's
just a lot of those streams
was overseas and it's crazy too because
a lot of [ __ ]
i don't understand i don't know how to
real gold certification or whatever
works because
it's like a lot of dudes who get those
plaques but youtube views ain't up there
but man got like 45 million and i'm
confused i'm like
on youtube yeah and i'm like how come
like my [ __ ]
is on [ __ ] you know what i think i i
know i know part of that is uh
i think youtube streams don't get
counted don't get the same way yeah the
same
like the same way especially if you're
[ __ ] like was is that is
it's on your channel right yeah then
they should count them because i know if
your shit's on worldstar a lot of
artists who might be watching this
if you up obviously if you upload the
world star
you've got a big audience because they
got [ __ ] 15 million subscribers
but since it's on someone else's channel
it doesn't go towards your certification
yeah so there's a lot of people who [ __ ]
is like you know
50 60 million on world star but those
views don't count towards
the song certification because it's not
on their channel which is kind of wild
or it might just be streams or something
you know what i'm saying facts facts um
but no we're talking about
uh obviously the mandel record but you
know
you and uh and uh nell dropped the
yellow tape and um yellow tape two was
this year right yeah yeah
which is crazy because it feel like it
came out last year this year has been a
[ __ ]
weird year wow we're the weirdest yeah
but um would you and
what about you and mazzy i i think
that's like a natural
it's natural well i'm talking talks with
davo and him about like
uh collab project we're still thinking
about it
i got like a couple like ideas in mind
but collab projects
i don't even want or i might do one with
them or not might we are actually with
um
phoenix flexing from shoreline mafia oh
that would be crazy
uh a video and to the fans that say it
was good chemistry so it was good
chemistry
might as well do more right yo that'd be
big for the city man
i think too that's what stuff about you
you being independent is you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want like if you
want to do a full project with somebody
you're like yo let's go
ain't nothing holding you back who's
someone who you're a fan of
um that that you haven't gotten to work
with that like maybe like
you know you you've kind of came up on
over the last couple years musically
um right now i [ __ ] with a lot of
little baby [ __ ]
which i i almost had the chance to do a
feature with him
but he reschedule it and i got in my
feelings and i said man [ __ ] that he
rescheduled it because it was better be
another big day for me
and and then the ticket was low that
time now his ticket is through the roof
you know what i'm saying
i [ __ ] with a little baby [ __ ] polo g
[ __ ] i got a record for polo g
poetry is crazy just waiting to pull
that trigger yep polo i [ __ ] with polo g
[ __ ] little baby a little tj a lot of
[ __ ] who just
do that new autotune wave [ __ ] but like
melodic [ __ ] yeah but they tell that
and paulo g could wrap his [ __ ] ass
off yeah follow g a rapper for real
um what curious what was the ticket for
little babies feature back back when you
could have got it twenty bands
damn for video and verse in the studio
recording in the studio all that because
you know my engine my engineer he record
he engineered
like a lot of [ __ ] and he's
always tied didn't he always keep me in
the loop
right you know shout out casey and um
yeah it was probably 20 but he
rescheduling and i was like man you know
what [ __ ] that [ __ ]
and then boom now because now it's 100
bands just for the first
do you feel like uh that was like a
lesson learned like about ego because i
feel like sometimes we get caught up in
our pride and [ __ ] and
but it's not like everything you do
every every in your career or you know
it's like a win or lose you know what
i'm saying
like you win some you lose some like
like nipsey i waited too long for him
and he wasn't charging [ __ ] i just
waited too long i wanted him
because he was my honestly my favorite
rapper growing up
nipsey yeah nipsey my whole section my
whole city well not well with all the
asians long beach [ __ ] with nipsey
nah nipsey's uh i think nipsey for the
la i mean [ __ ] i
first came on his [ __ ] oh nine and yeah
for sure it wasn't got no name volume
two i believe was the first project i
heard from him rest in peace to nip
yeah it's crazy because like i feel like
just in general man like
la the wave in la right now is extremely
strong and it's very i feel like it's
the strongest it's been in a very long
time i also feel like there's a lot of
camaraderie
as to where maybe in the past there
wasn't as much of that like i feel like
for the most part
everyone [ __ ] with each other i know
that there is it's l.a so politics get
involved
you know what i'm saying but i think for
the most part like you know you kind of
see the landscape of la hip-hop
everyone's [ __ ] with each other
everyone's working with each other
um like is that like like
do you consider yourself a leader of the
new la [ __ ]
uh yeah no because like when they talk
about la
it'll be like west west coast or
whatever like yeah for sure but like
like long beach always wanted to be his
own long beach is his own city you know
of course of course
so i was like i feel like i'm just i'm
i'm i'm a long beach dude you know what
i'm saying
because la got their own [ __ ] but then
long beach just falls under the la
category so you can say
it's like a year to no thing i mean yeah
like look snoop's the biggest rapper
ever from long beach but i mean
everybody looks
it's a west coast [ __ ] you know what i'm
saying sure for sure yeah
like you know what about um shout out to
uh
you know when it comes to long beach
there's snoop otu
um savvy's dope
uh what who who in your opinion is
is outside of snoop dogg who do you
think is the greatest
long beach nc ever besides
besides snoop i think nate dawg yo for
show nate dawg
not quite a rapper but you know he's
he's a legend for sure
a legend for sure was what was warren g
from long beach yeah he from long beach
yeah warren g too yup warren g is dope
too but oh [ __ ]
oh that [ __ ] you just gotta yeah slide
it back on but i feel like nate dog is
just
one of a kind nate dog was that guy i
don't think anyone's ever had the hook
bag it was like nate dog it was a con
t-pain and then that's really it
you know you could who i think blast
blast
blast right now is gonna be that guy to
be that hook i think ty had a clue
has has had a run ties had a run blast
but blast i think
different that's an artist artist for
sure keeper people yeah yeah yeah blast
is an
alien you and blas got anything together
yeah we got a record we got a record
it's just not out
is it it's not on the album either no
probably come on next year but we got a
record
cause i know you're sitting on a lot of
music so like a lot yeah like a lot a
lot
all the show i'm dropping now i've been
doing it it's probably recorded last
year
i just like to move a couple of steps
ahead you know what i'm saying like i'm
about to drop this project
right now but i'm also working on other
[ __ ] i mean [ __ ] man
next year that's the way to go
independent for sure i mean [ __ ] mazzy
dropped two albums this year
everybody was dropping multiple [ __ ]
this year are you ever inspired by any
any like east coast [ __ ]
like as a rapper because i feel like you
you could rap you know what i'm saying
and
yeah yeah when i grew up i always
thought rapping was gonna stay like that
lyrical
so i was always like alright i'm gonna
do some lyrical [ __ ] because i could i'm
like i'm versatile i could do the
lyrical [ __ ]
i could do like the party [ __ ] i could
do the melodic [ __ ] whatever but
yeah i [ __ ] with east coast music before
i [ __ ] with davey's tough davies is fire
that's true
if i had to bet on a rapper from the
east that you [ __ ] with davies would
probably be just based on you know the
you know the you know yeah for sure
shout out to and dave is so tapped in in
l.a
i feel like everybody in l.a [ __ ] with
dave dave's a solid [ __ ] dude man
shout out
oh we're uh breaking down this video
we're not breaking it down we're taking
a break in the video
to tell you all about our sponsors odd
socks all right listen man
uh odd socks official.com the [ __ ] was
that bro
uh it was like a [ __ ] pomeranian hair
floating in air
anyway odd socksofficial.com keyword
bootleg kev
go over there get you some socks and
you'll save 20
off if you use that keyword they got
south park license
they got some ghostbusters pimp c mike
tyson
really the one that i really care about
is they got that wwe license you can get
these awesome nwo socks
and then they got their odd socks basics
you know for all the basic [ __ ] get
you some basic socks
even though they are very comfortable
they're probably the most comfortable
socks actually not probably definitively
the most comfortable socks i've ever put
on my feet
yes alright and that goes for all types
of socks
so go to oddssocksofficial.com get some
socks by the way
spongebob socks the kind of fly right
christmas time is on the way
use the keyword boolean kev 20 off
oddssoxoficial.com
support us by supporting odd socks let's
go what about um you obviously working
with t grizzly doing the video i feel
like you guys are kind of made for each
other sonically
yeah yeah you know i feel like you guys
love the same kind of production
how did that uh relationship and that
record happen man um
i just seen him follow me and i just
tapped in with him
and he's like i'm like when you gonna be
in l.a like you know i'm out here in l.a
all the time so i'm like
sent them the record and it just made it
happen
and he invited me to his uh video shoot
for a single he wanted he let me be in a
video which was cool too
um his single off the project off uh
off his last album he just dropped
produced by dj mustard yeah yeah
i wasn't on it i was just in the end of
the year which was dope i feel like yeah
[ __ ] with dude he pulled up and did the
video too yeah for sure
you have to you know i mean with someone
like t like i know he's a real ass dude
like is that like
like hey look let's do a swap like come
do my video yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure
that's dope yeah for sure
you know yeah because [ __ ] with you it
worked like that that's how it works
when's the last time you had to pay for
a feature
it's been a while for real it's been a
while yeah but you you
like usually you still have to pay
something because you got to pay for the
video
yeah you got to pay for it like yo
listen fam if you need a
[ __ ] wardrobe or some food or i got
to get you your [ __ ] car to come over
to the shoot or
it's not as easy as like yo thanks just
pull up and you know do the video and
bounce and you know
yeah for sure it's all when you reach a
certain level you know what i'm saying
no 100 man um what is what is the one
thing uh
that 2020s taught you man
never take nothing for granted like
outside
restaurants and [ __ ] yeah never take
[ __ ] for granted
that's about it yeah that's some real
[ __ ] for sure so many things that we
just considered normal
yeah like watching the lakers or some
[ __ ] or like going to the movies simple
as [ __ ]
i don't think i think the movies are a
wrap for like forever
why why you say that i just don't think
that flicks and [ __ ] bro i just don't
think like these theaters are gonna
survive bro
like how these [ __ ] are gonna
be like
how long is it gonna take for people to
be comfortable to go sit in a theater
with [ __ ] 400 other people
yeah you know what i'm saying like how
long can these [ __ ] couples you got
some [ __ ] now with her though they got
some [ __ ] where you could rent the
theater out
you can't do that you and your people
that's what that's fire
yeah but like who's doing that you want
to take your [ __ ] to a movie
you don't want to take 50 people to a
movie you don't like call my parents
invite them
now i'm just trying to go with my girl
like low-key you know what i'm saying
get some food
date night is switched up in 2020. yeah
for sure
that [ __ ] yeah this this [ __ ] is crazy
um
i also wanted to talk to you about uh
you know
you you and now like you guys have a
dope chemistry obviously shout out to
stockton
um how did you guys outside of being
asian
and being from the west coast because
it's almost like
yeah of course they would do a project
together right like or two rather
and um yeah like talk about child's
relationship and
and um you know you guys got to relate
to each other because you guys kind of
are both some you know listen like you
said earlier
being an asian dude rapping it catches
people off guard a little bit yeah
uh i feel like like like i didn't
like know him before the music but when
i seen his first song i was just like
i relate to you know we both asian both
crips whatever i got a hood and my
neighborhood
down here is also in stockton and
i asked the homies hey man i'm gonna do
something with this dude um
he hard as [ __ ] y'all do like is there a
policies between that there was no
politics so we linked
and it was just love and it was just
like the [ __ ] i talk about is really
really really real like from my area and
the [ __ ] he talked about is really real
from his area you know what i'm saying
so i just it's just and then we lean it
was just good chemistry from there
that's that's dope um yeah
shout out to him man um i feel like both
y'all got your wave
and then the yellow tape was just a a
very genius uh
for sure dom kennedy had a yellow tape
did you know that when you guys did that
no i didn't think about nobody when we
did that i feel like it'll fit us more i
was gonna say
i was about to say you really can't like
with you really can't
nobody could say [ __ ] like yeah i get it
i get it
yeah i get it you know what i've said um
anything else on the horizon for you
like
you like are you expanding like you know
acting or anything different that that
that
is outside of the music situation i was
in like two movies
it just ain't now yeah they're chopping
it around i believe and then the covert
you know
stopped a lot of [ __ ] but other than
that nah man just keep working
raising my son finding ways to make
money and that's it
any more children you want to have more
kids my girl want more kids that you sad
but
of course she does buy her a dog
i'm like man you you having a hard time
just [ __ ] cleaning this big ass house
and watching one son you want another
one just buying them
buy her a dog bro she want a dog for
sure let's just get her the puppy and
that'll that'll put it like a 12-month
band-aid on the problem
i need longer than that yeah he said i
need three four years [ __ ]
i'm gonna get three dogs a show hey i
wanted to ask you this because obviously
being in la
um is it has there ever been a situation
where you might have wanted to have
worked with someone
or you didn't work with someone even
though there was no like bad blood
because of the politics
yeah i'm in that situation a lot even
without music like
it's weird because there's a lot of
policies but like i could do something
historical with this person
and then there's just a lot of politics
behind that you know what i'm saying
but it's like i did i did [ __ ] with some
essays where
the mexicans who we are cool with in the
city didn't get along with you know what
i'm saying
but it was all about business and
bridging that gap
like like i'm all about bridging that
gap unless you're like my super number
one ops and that's that's never gonna
happen
right right right but it was like a
little attention issue i'm pretty sure
it could bridge that gap and make
history happen and [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying but yeah it's
always politics for sure even
including us you know what i'm saying
it's always politics
give me the the i guess the difference
between
you know the asian section of where
you're from
and then like what is the difference
between the like
obviously historically we think of crips
from long beach they look a certain way
and and people who aren't from long
beach or who don't who aren't aware of
the asian presence right
like if you're someone who's from like
[ __ ] wichita kansas and you're like
wait there's
asian crips you know what i'm saying
like what is the difference
and if if any and like how does how does
it kind of fit into the
the grand scheme of of everything when
it comes to that [ __ ] without getting
like obviously
too too into it well [ __ ] you know like
um
how we formed was because the uh
cambodian khmer rouge
war which is very slept on they only
know about like hitler and
the holocaust and [ __ ] like that but it
was killing the ruler cambodia was
killing millions of our people
like millions he just wanted to
eliminate everybody and they were doing
that and it was like one point something
million cambodians getting killed
through the whole country
wow and no it was very slept on it and i
forgot what president
what year was this this is like the 70s
[ __ ]
so then like late 70s so then
my dad and [ __ ] was already born and
[ __ ] over there my mom they were young
very young kids and then um
i forgot what president was at the time
i don't know regan or
reagan was regan reagan or jimmy jimmy
carter maybe reagan if it was
reagan or somebody early 80s late 70s
it's like reagan jimmy carter yeah i'm
thinking reagan but
i could be wrong don't quote me on it
but they were they helped out and they
went over there and they brought us over
here and then some you know they brought
i think the vietnam via vietnam helped
us but they brought us over here and the
large
there was two places where a large um
group of cambodians went to and
number one were the most ones it was
long beach california and then the
second one was
boston massachusetts that's where we
have a hood as well and it was just like
we came over here and the other races
the blacks and hispanics in long beach
wasn't used to us
but we were mainly beefing with the
hispanics and then the blacks was
already beefing with the hispanics and
then their blacks were crips and long
beach is the only city in the u.s
whereas all [ __ ] city there's not one
blood hood you know what i'm saying
either you
a [ __ ] or you're a south side or a
mexican you know
so we we adapted to the community and
became crips that's how people and then
it just spread like wildfire
and we're different because we're just
like i don't know we just programmed
different
i don't think yeah how disconnected is
the long beach politics from like la
politics because you know obviously and
even in the valley there's like pacoima
and you know it's very it's very
disconnected we're like well us
is disconnected but it's kind of like
our neighborhood is
like our art like my neighborhood from
in long beach was also in
the sfv was in van nuys they were also
in san gabriel valley they're also in
orange county
so like they beef with those
neighborhoods which brings it to us
because it's like you be for one you be
for all you know what i'm saying
but then it's like it's disconnected but
it's kind of connected it's like you
know what i'm saying
do you have do you feel like um being
like like do you are you do you feel
like you're a role model for like young
young kids that look like you out of
your city yeah
for sure do you take that like to the
heart because i feel like you know
when you you really can you know maybe
steer some kids the right direction
yeah i kind of want them to be do be
like you could be successful
without getting locked up or end up dead
and and being
you could be cool because everyone as a
kid want to be do what everyone is doing
be the cool kids you know what i'm
saying
you can be cool and and successful and
without taking the same path i took you
know what i'm saying
yeah like i think that you know
obviously we all are where we are
because of our life experiences and you
probably shouldn't regret much in life
you know what i'm saying but you know if
you could help steer
uh steer somebody a different direction
because you already walked that path for
them you know what i mean
yeah for sure what's your favorite song
on this album
damn that's a horror one um
oh no i got a lot of i got a lot of
favorite ones
i got that one the one i sent you yeah
that one i feel like you sent me like
four records
the one that i liked though remember i
think it was called uh is it
is it's late it's called stupid
freestyle but it's titled
yeah it's titled that but it's really
called stupid freestyle and it's just no
hook no nothing i'm just going on yeah
i never rap like fast like that before
well you actually freestyle
yeah yeah cause when you came on our on
me and head show uh you was actually off
the top of the head for a lot of that
[ __ ]
for sure and a lot of people can't do
that yeah for sure a lot of people
that's not what they do they're like
you're just telling me
that i ain't got nothing ready yeah you
know you was coming off the top of the
head for sure so
yeah we had all kinds of people like who
is this asian guy saying the n-word on
your
show sure yeah it's crazy
do you have you um like
you've gotten obviously critiqued for
using the n-word
writing your music and [ __ ] all the time
all the time like
is that something that you've uh evolved
on at all i've listened to your music
like the new [ __ ] i never understood
i learned to ignore it because it's like
that at the end of the day that's how i
grew up that's how i was raised the
environment i was raised
and it's a it's a saying that i always
say they threw
tarzan in the jungle and he came out
like that you know what i'm saying
he didn't come out a different way there
was like it doesn't matter what the
environment you raise
you have your own action and choices no
it doesn't it
doesn't it does matter your environment
makes you who you are
in a way you know most of the time at
least like you know like 80
80 90 i'm part of the 80 90 yeah for
sure
like you could tell me to stop saying
the n word or this and that but as soon
as the
i start rapping or this now and i go
back to my regular life that's who i am
i'm still be like that to the
until i [ __ ] some has that ever
costed you any opportunities or features
or relationships
not that i know of yeah it could be
someone didn't want to [ __ ] with me
because of that but
i didn't do that you just don't know
about it yeah yeah that's well listen
man
you you could rap man the music is solid
um the project
is is officially out now because this is
coming out afterwards
um and then you got you i mean what
songs we talking about you got features
ready for
uh blue face on there t grizzly you got
mike sherman
um ot genesis yeah yeah
you and snoop ever worked together yet
yeah i'm on his last album yeah you are
on it
he did like a whole long beach record
yup yup yeah
shout out to snoop man still be tapping
in sure was that like a
bucket list thing like working with
snoop dogg being a kid from long beach
it was
it was and now it's just like it's just
done
for like move on you know yeah no how
like did you were you in the studio
snoop nah it was email through email
but he mentioned me you know what i'm
saying on like was it case
sway in the morning or like all these
interviews he's like yeah man i got
stupid on there i got
origin you know what i'm saying would
you like to ever smoke with snoop
nah no i smoked a soup one time and i
was like
you got to man you got to huh even if
like you don't want to you just like
it's like bro
it's like even if you don't smoke you
have to it's like it's like
there's a few of those guys it's like
willie nelson whiz snoop
seth rogan you know what i mean like you
go smoke with these guys yeah i'm saying
but look man
stupid young i appreciate you coming
through go go support the project
um and uh you you got the merch and all
that [ __ ] dropping yup yup
officials um officials label.com that's
where you get the merch at
from here on our drop in 1218 make sure
y'all tap in
yeah from here on out it's out and then
there's gonna be a lot more music next
year
sure hopefully we'll be on the road next
year yeah hopefully
yeah go [ __ ] it up in arizona again i
remember seeing yeah
he was on the mozzie tour out there yeah
yeah yeah that was it wait didn't you
did you come to the club that night
no you had like a young a young kid with
you i had too much young people yeah
yeah
yo your entourage was too young yeah for
sure
this one was like yo fam he's like i
forget how the kid was young though he
was like can you get him in and i was
like
i was like bro i can't do nothing there
if he was 18 at least i could you know
yeah he said 15. i said [ __ ]
yeah anyway stupid young bootleg kev go
support the album